[Music]
you're back
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
excuse me
so that's the ex-girlfriend is it the
old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane
foster the one that got away the one
that got away that means escaped yeah
yeah
must be hard for you to see your
ex-girlfriend and your ex hammer hanging
out and getting on so well
what you up to bro
[Music]
go to daddy
[Music]
hey
there you are
hey
i was just calling you
me
they're in the shadow realm how do you
know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like
no other it's as if color feels to tread
it's unmistakable well then if it's
color we need
let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbows her catchphrase or
something she's only been a thor for a
minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have they
been a lot
yep
jump the gun hang on he moves through
shadows and he's going to the shadow
realm it seems like that's where he's
going to be the most powerful you're
right we can't just go marching in there
it could be a trap are you thinking what
i think you're thinking i'm thinking it
what are we thinking thinking we're
taking it too
god of thunder king khan
you have finally joined our fight well
they say better late than not at all
this is very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful oasis but in our gods were
murdered murdered and now our sacred
temple has been left unguarded and
hopeful
to control of its power it is our most
sacred shrine and it desecrates not for
long
king you can't
tell them what happened here today tell
us the time that thor
the drag tag motley crew misfit
desperados turn the tide in the battle
and that's their names in history the
odds may be against us but i'll tell you
this for free here we go this
and
here and now
oh
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
i'm putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
[Music]
[Music]
valkyrie this is the best
[Music]
they also scream quite a lot
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
human handshake
to the asgardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging us out and finish the
classic asgardian high one
in theaters july 8 tickets on sale now
day 62 intentions are running sky high
on the set of love and thunder because
this mood is an all-time low so i'm
about to go and help pick up the spirits
with my bubbly energetic personality
[Music]
this is ten years for me i have loved
every time i played the character this
new film transitions us from end game
into a rebirth for doesn't know what his
place is in the universe
that's represented in his wardrobe as
well
i was really excited to come back as the
mighty thor and get to share the mantle
i love it to have both of us in the same
cape
um that was amazing and incredible
especially with tyka at the helm tucker
he's like a big kid like sort of a
genius child i wasn't afraid to be
flamboyant and a bit camp
three two one
giant goats look at those they are
wonderful yes they are they also scream
quite a lot
it's hugely imaginative and fun like
such an enormous scale
it's a crazy space adventure with a new
villain he's pretty monstrous
oh god she won't die
we really raise the bar with ragnarok
love and thunder is even more unique and
different so it's pretty exciting
[Music]
[Music]
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odenson
he was no ordinary man
he was a
god after saving planet earth for the
500th time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god bod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's the family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
am i um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back
[Music]
he's there my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
you
are not like the other gods that kill
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
[Music]
you